[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICKEY KATARIA: Hello.
Good afternoon.
My name is Mickey Kataria, and
welcome to the Android for Cars
session at Google I/O.
AUDIENCE: Woo-hoo!
MICKEY KATARIA: Thank you.
It's hard for me to
believe that this is now
our sixth year at Google I/O
talking about Android and cars.
Here is our first
time back in 2014,
when we unveiled the Android
Auto onstage at Moscone
in San Francisco.
A fun fact from that
day, by the way,
the sled that we had up
on stage was actually
one of our first
test Kia Soul cars
that we transformed
specifically for that purpose.
Rest assured, it's since found
a happy home in our team area,
where we still use it every
day for demos and testing.
Even before Android Auto, our
investments and commitments
in the industry go back
almost 15 years at Google.
We know that cars stay on
the road for a very long time
and are an important part
of people's daily lives.
That's why over the
last decade, we've
continued to only
increase our investments
and broaden our partnerships
with the automotive industry,
and we expect that trend to
continue for the coming decade
as well.
One thing that's
remained constant
throughout all of those
years is our vision,
and that is to bring a safe and
seamless connected experience
into every car.
A big part of making that
experience and this vision
a reality is to have a
consistent, reliable,
and extensible
platform like Android
that enables us to bring modern
services easily into the car.
With Android as an
underlying platform,
we think we can seamlessly
connect the user's digital life
from outside of
the car to what's
happening inside of the car.
What that means is the
same apps and services
that you use on your phones,
laptops, other smart devices--
those same apps and services
can be brought easily
into the car with Android as
a shared underlying platform.
And if we do our
job well, we think
that the experience in the
car will be very personalized
and deeply integrated.
I've personally had the
opportunity to build and shape
many of the in-car
products that we've
brought to market
over the years,
and they've gone through
three phases of investment.
We started back in 2005, when
we first worked with Audi and VW
to bring Google Earth
into their cars.
It's a great product.
It's still on the road today,
many drivers still going
with it, but the challenge was
taking a desktop app-- a client
app like Google Earth--
and porting it to run
on a proprietary platform.
That required a lot
of effort and we
found it virtually impossible
to keep the software up
to date over time.
So we pivoted in our
second phase of investment
to a different approach.
We started to open up
Cloud-based APIs, primarily
in Maps and local, so that
connected cars could pull
in specific features, like
Street View, as shown here,
and incorporate them and tie
them into the built-in car
navigation systems.
You can see many of
these cars on the road
today, from partners like Tesla,
BMW, Mercedes, and many more.
And while the API
approach meant that we
didn't have to port any
client software into cars,
what we didn't
anticipate was how
ubiquitous and common
smartphones would become over
that period of time--
so much so that drivers
were increasingly
turning to familiar and
intuitive applications
on their phones
even when they had
access to these in-car
advanced navigation systems.
So finally, in our
third and most recent
phase of investment, and
what brings us here today,
we looked at the
phone strategy, and we
saw how important it was to have
an Android as a common platform
that could enable us and
developers everywhere
to bring services--
modern services--
easily into the car
and build great,
up-to-date experiences.
And that is how we
started the effort
to bring Android into cars.
One of the first investments
behind in-car products
is on the phone screen itself.
With more than one
billion cars on the road
today, we know that the phone
is a part of many, many drives
already.
And we want to do our part
to make that experience
safer as well.
At the I/O keynote
this morning, you
heard about the Google
Assistant's driving mode.
Here you see it displayed
in a dark theme.
This driving mode is a new way
to use your phone in a safer
and helpful way in your car.
This project brings
together the best
of designing for our driving
experience from several teams
across Google, including
the Android Auto team,
and it also represents
the next step
in evolution of the Android
Auto phone-screen experience.
Stay tuned for
more details as we
migrate users from the Android
Auto phone-screen experience
to the Google Assistant
driving mode later this year.
Beyond the phone screen,
we have two major products
for the car screen itself.
The first is Android Auto,
which we unveiled in 2014,
and launched to
consumers in 2015.
This has Android Auto
technology running on the phone
and integrating
with compatible cars
to bring your favorite
apps and services directly
to the car screen,
and then you can
interact with these apps and
services in a natural way,
using your car's touchscreen,
rotary controller,
or otherwise.
Meanwhile, all the software
is running on the phone.
It's exciting for us to see that
since 2015, Android Auto has
become virtually an
industry standard.
And it's also humbling for
us to see that consumers
will increasingly not
buy a new car if it
ships without Android Auto.
The second major product
for the car screen
is the Android Automotive OS.
This is Android
running in the car
as the embedded
infotainment platform,
and it powers a much deeper,
more seamless experience
for everything-- from
navigating with Google Maps,
to listening to
music with Spotify,
to controlling
vehicle functions,
like cabin or seat temperature.
We can also enable
richer user experiences,
like showing
contextual visual maps,
as you see in the
cluster display
here, as infotainment
itself expands
from being in one central
screen to multiple screens
and gets more deeply integrated
into the car as well.
And unlike Android Auto,
your apps and services
are running on the
car, so it doesn't
matter what kind
of phone you have,
or even if you forgot
your phone at home.
The name Android
Automotive OS, by the way,
is directed primarily
towards developers,
so that they know the
underlying platform
for which they're
developing their services
is based on Android.
We think consumers are
more likely to notice
familiar brands that
they already use
on their smart devices, like
Google Maps, or iHeart Radio,
or Spotify, when they're
in the market looking
at one of these
cars that's powered
by Android under the hood.
One of the questions
that we sometimes
get when we talk about these
two projects side by side
is, is Android Automotive OS
going to replace Android Auto?
The short answer is no.
We think that both
products-- both experiences--
will continue to
grow for a long time,
and ultimately offer both
users and our OEM partners
a choice in what to
bring into the car.
We also think that
the phone and the car
will actually work
together better over time
to create the best experience
possible for drivers
and passengers.
You can see some of
that today already,
as cars rely on phones for
things like making phone calls.
And we think that experience
will get better and tighter,
so that when you do have
your phone with you,
the entire experience
of the phone of the car,
working together will
be truly seamless.
So with that, I want
to focus on Android
Auto for a couple
of minutes and talk
about the fantastic
momentum that we've
been seeing over the last year.
And I'll touch on how the
momentum is coming together
through growth,
hardware, and software.
In terms of global
reach, Android Auto
is available today
in 36 markets.
We added five more markets
in the last few months,
and rest assured,
we know that there
are many more markets
to reach out there,
and we are working hard to get
into many, many more of those
in the coming months.
On the partnership
front, Android Auto
is already available in more
than 500 car models from more
than 50 different brands.
Earlier this year,
Toyota announced
that they will be shipping cars
with Android Auto from later
this year.
We are very, very excited to
have them on board and working
together to reach
more and more drivers.
With Toyota onboard, nearly
every major global automotive
OEM is now shipping Android
Auto compatible cars,
and together, these
committed partners
represent more than
95% of the industry.
So thank you to our
amazing partners
for helping us bring this
fantastic, safe, and seamless
experience to every
driver on the road.
Google I/O would, of course,
not exist without developers,
and we've already seen
fantastic momentum here,
and it's one of the great
reasons for the success
of Android Auto.
We're continuing to see many,
many more apps join the Android
Auto list of compatible
apps, and I just
want to highlight a few
notable names that have
appeared over the last year.
With our launch
in South Korea, we
saw local media apps Bugs and
Melon support Android Auto,
and we also welcomed Apple
Music, YouTube Music,
and Google Podcasts to the
list of compatible apps.
Thank you to all the
amazing developers
for helping make Android Auto
such a fantastic experience
for drivers out there.
We have a dedicated
session for you,
also tomorrow morning,
where we talk much more
about how to build and
adapt your app for cars.
And we continue to invest
in making our platform
and enabling newer and
better experiences on top
of the solid base that we've
already built together.
All of these great
partnerships and new markets
add up to one big number for us.
We are on track to have
Android Auto in more than 100
million cars in the next year.
We are super proud and
excited to be able to get this
far with all of your support.
As I've said in
the beginning, we
know that being in
automotive requires
a long-term commitment.
So getting from our first car
in 2015 to our 100 millionth car
in 2020 hopefully shows you that
we are here for the long run.
Switching to hardware
improvements that
are allowing us to
reach more drivers,
we recently launched
support for a touchpad
as an input mechanism.
So if you have a car with
one of these devices,
you can now effortlessly
navigate the Android Auto UI.
We expect more of our
partners to be shipping
touchpad in their cars,
so enabling this now
lets us reach more drivers, and
more users, and the more cars
starting today.
The wireless support, which
we announced last year,
has been an absolute
game changer
for how you use this product.
You no longer have
to take the phone out
of your pocket or your
bag and plug it in.
You can get in your car and
have Android Auto ready to go
by the time you want to drive.
We've already seen great
support from partners
like JVC, Kenwood,
and Pioneer, who
have been shipping aftermarket
head units over the last year.
And if you are in the
market for a new car,
you'll be excited to know that
the first cars with the Android
Auto wireless support
built in will be shipping
before the end of this year.
And switching to
software improvements,
we've hit some pretty
big milestones just
since last year, and I want to
highlight a couple of things.
First, we launched a
new and improved UI
for browsing and
playback of media.
Second, we launched support
for search in media apps,
so that a driver can
easily find the exact song
or podcast that
they're looking for.
And third, we launched
and enabled support
for group messaging,
so it's much easier
to stay in touch with
friends and family
when you're on the go with
a voice-powered experience.
We also released
an update recently
for widescreens, where
Android Auto can now
offer a much better
seamless experience.
For ultra widescreens,
as shown here,
it can also have Maps and
media running side by side,
allowing the driver to
accomplish more tasks easily,
while keeping their
focus on the road.
So beyond some of
these features,
We also continue
to invest deeply
in our core UI for Android Auto.
Yesterday, we announced
some big design improvements
to the Android Auto
experience that
make it easier for consumers
to see and access the apps
and information that they want.
So I'd like to
invite Ian Barlow,
one of our lead designers,
who's been working on many
of these changes to come and
share some more about what
we're doing here.
[APPLAUSE]
IAN BARLOW: Thanks, Mickey.
We have a lot of really big
changes coming to Android Auto
soon, and I'm so excited
to show them to you today.
But before I do, I'd
like to talk a little bit
about how we got
to them, give you
a little bit of the backstory.
As Mickey mentioned,
Android Auto
has really become
an industry standard
for automotive
infotainment experiences.
People are actually basing their
new car purchase decisions on
whether the car
has Android Auto.
Well, that's amazing.
But we also know that there's
still room for improvement.
And we haven't gotten
everything right along the way.
We've heard from our users that
there are some core usability
problems with the
current system,
and it hasn't really been
updated in the last four years,
and it feels kind
of out of date.
And so we've been
thinking about this a lot.
How do we evolve the user
experience of the product
to feel more intuitive,
and how do we
elevate the design language
to feel more modern,
and like it's actually
made for the car?
Some of you may even
remember last year at I/O,
we previewed some
of the concepts
that we've been working on.
Well, today I'm going to
go into a lot more detail,
and show you specifically what's
coming next on Android Auto.
We've completely overhauled
the design language,
we've built a system that's
more scalable and flexible and
adapts to more screen
sizes and inputs,
and we've refined a lot
of those usability issues,
and crafted an experience
that's much more intuitive
and feels like a
natural extension
of your phone in the car.
So let's start with
the design language.
For those of you who
use Android Auto,
you probably know it looks
like an earlier version,
like earlier material
design product.
It has really
bright, poppy colors.
It has kind of a
lighter UI theme,
and it looks pretty cool.
But it also doesn't really
fit that well in the car.
It looks a little
bit out of place.
And so we've been
thinking about that a lot.
And when we set out to
refine the design language,
we wanted to make something
that felt where seamlessly
integrated into the car.
And so we drew a lot
of our inspiration
from automotive
interior design--
the dark color palettes,
the neutral themes,
the sophisticated materials, the
way textures and accent colors
draw attention to
core functions--
but that the whole experience
is designed to sit back
and focus the drivers
attention on the road.
And we took that inspiration,
and we combined it
with the best of material design
to craft an all-new Google
design language for driving,
a dark UI theme that
looks right at home in the car.
And so to do that,
we actually adapted
parts of material design.
We took the gray values
that existed today,
and we expanded them to
create a richer spectrum
in the dark range that helped
us build a more flexible UI,
and something that looks
much more sophisticated.
We even refined the
material Accent Blue
to make sure that it
displayed properly in cars
and met contrast.
And we've also improved the
legibility of the system
by moving to a more
extended typefaces
like Robot Regular and
Medium and even Google Sans.
We also layered that
into a type scale
that's easily glanceable and
adheres to our strict driver
distraction and
safety guidelines.
And so all of this coalesces
into a new visual system that
looks right at home in the
car, minimizes distraction,
and it looks gorgeous.
Now this new system
is also designed
to be much more
scalable, and designed
so that it can fit into
the wider, and larger,
and taller screens that
are coming into cars today.
So the idea is you can plug
your phone into any car,
and it'll always be
recognizably Android Auto,
but it will always also make the
best possible use of the screen
that it's on.
But as I was saying--
oh, sorry-- it also supports
voice and any other input
your car supports, whether
it has a touch-screen,
uses a rotary controller,
or as Mickey was mentioning,
uses a touchpad.
But this redesign
went so much deeper
than aesthetics and
scalability alone.
We've also made great
strides towards improving
the overall usability
of the system.
We've heard from
people today that it's
hard to switch media apps.
When messages come in, they
don't know where they go.
It's hard to find.
And that the whole system
feels like something
that has to be
learned, and doesn't
feel as intuitive as it could.
And so we asked ourselves,
how can we improve that?
How can we help people get
started faster on their drive?
How can we simplify
the kinds of key tasks
that people do while driving?
How do we provide the right
information at a glance,
and make it easier
for people to access
their content and
their apps, and create
a more intuitive
experience that feels more
like your phone in the car?
And so all of these things--
the new design language,
better scalability,
usability improvements--
are effectively the building
blocks of this new experience.
And when you put
them all together,
here's what it looks like.
A brand new version
of Android Auto
that's easier to use than ever.
For drivers, it's
a gorgeous new UI
that provides the right
information at the right time,
and for developers, this
is an all-new system
that's going to
increase exposure
to your products in
the car, and also lays
the groundwork for
future innovation.
So let's take a closer look.
First of all, we've completely
redesigned the navigation bar
to make it easier to access
your apps, your notifications,
and your Google Assistant.
And it's quite a bit
simpler than it is today.
And we did this
partly so that we
could develop a new
kind of system widget
that lets you control
ongoing content while you're
in another app.
And so what that
means is, you could
be using Maps to navigate,
and still have one-tap access
to skip songs in your media
app, to skip back or forward
in your podcast or audio book.
You can even control
an ongoing phone call,
all while keeping a full view
of your map on the screen.
And if you do leave
Maps for a second,
let's say to find
something new to listen
to, well, that
widget adapts itself,
so you'll always see important
next-turn information
on screen.
This is a really
powerful new feature,
and it provides drivers
with the information they
need at exactly the right time.
We've been driving around with
this for the last few months,
and I have to say it
is a game changer.
Tasks that used to take
three or four taps in the car
can now be completed
with a single tap.
And what's even better
is that if you're
a developer who already has a
media app that runs on Android
Auto, this new widget feature
will automatically work
with your app from day one.
There is nothing
extra you need to do.
We're also making it faster
and more intuitive for drivers
to access their favorite Android
Auto apps through this newly
redesigned launcher.
This addresses another
one of those key usability
concerns I had
mentioned earlier,
where people have a hard time
finding the rest of their apps
in the system.
And for developers, this
will also drive more usage
for your product because
they'll be displayed much more
prominently in the
Android Auto system.
So the launcher is great for
starting new experiences.
But what about
responding to things
as they come into the car?
Well, the new Android Auto
still supports notifications
as it does today.
You never miss out on a new
phone call as it comes in,
or a new message.
But what's more is
we've also moved these
into a new dedicated
Notification Center that's
always a single tap away
in the navigation bar.
So when you're driving,
you can focus on the road,
and you won't have to
worry about responding
to that message right away
if it's not the right time,
because you can always
easily get back to it
with a single tap.
Now when this new
Android Auto system,
we're also still
leveraging the same APIs
for both notification-based
messaging apps,
as well as our templatized
media app experiences.
So again, if you're already
along for the journey with us
and you've developed an app
either in media or messaging
that works for
Android Auto today,
there's nothing
new that you need
to do as part of
this new system.
Your app will still
work, and as you can see,
it will look great, like
it was made for the car.
We are so excited about this
update for Android Auto.
It'll be available this summer
in all Android Auto-enabled
vehicles.
But in the meantime, please make
sure to swing by our sandbox
for a demo in our Hyundai Kona.
We'd love to show
you more about it.
Now I'm going to hand
it back to Mickey, who's
going to tell you what else
we're doing to bring Android
into cars.
MICKEY KATARIA: Thank you, Ian.
The new UI looks awesome
Please come check it out.
And we cannot wait to share it
with you starting this summer.
I'd like to go back now just
for a second to our vision
statement and really
focus on the seamless part
of the statement.
With a phone-powered
UI that's running side
by side with the built-in or
native experience in the car,
we see clear seams in
the user experience,
where our driver has the switch
between the native system
and the phone system to be able
to accomplish all their tasks.
For example, you might be
using the built-in system
to adjust the cabin
temperature, and then you
switch into Android
Auto when you want
to use Google Maps or Spotify.
So also, as infotainment
expands into multiple screens,
like in the cluster display
I was showing earlier,
and it gets more and more
deeply integrated into the car,
it gets more challenging
to be able to create
one unified seamless
experience just from the phone.
So we knew that we
had a lot of work
ahead of us to continue
to enable this vision
statement of creating a unified,
seamless-- completely seamless
experience.
So a few years ago, we
started to talk to car makers
about how we could
work together to create
this unified,
seamless experience.
Not surprisingly,
many car makers
were already
experimenting with Android
or using it in their
cars for infotainment,
but there was a lot of
work to be done to adapt
Android from mobile to the car.
So we started to
invest at that time
in making Android
a turnkey solution
that industry partners could
take and bring into the car
easily without having to
make significant changes,
without having to change any
of the core framework or APIs
that make the Android platform
so great for developers today.
You may have seen some of
the demos and prototypes
that we showed the
last couple of years
with Android running under
the hood and many Google
and third-party
apps running on top.
One of the first
partners who we spoke
with who got very excited about
working with us on this project
was Volvo.
We engaged with them
a couple of years ago
and formally announced
our partnership last year
to bring Android, and Google
Maps, the Google Assistant,
and the third-party
app ecosystem
through the Google Play
Store to all of their cars.
Volvo, in turn, introduced
us to their performance
and electric brand Polestar.
And just a few weeks ago,
at the Geneva Auto Show,
they unveiled the Polestar
2 that you see here.
This will be the first consumer
vehicle launching in 2020
to ship with the seamless
experience that brings together
Android, Google Apps, and the
third party app ecosystem.
To tell you more about
the car, the technology,
and our partnership, we asked
Polestar CEO Thomas Ingenlath
to join us here today.
Thomas has been the CEO of
Polestar since June 2017,
and also serves as the Chief
Design Officer of Volvo Car
Corporation.
Previously, he was a Senior Vice
President of Design at Volvo
and has been the
inspiration behind Volvo's
award-winning design
renaissance for years.
Welcome, Thomas.
[APPLAUSE]
THOMAS INGENLATH: Thank you.
Thanks, Mickey.
Hi.
My name is Thomas Ingenlath.
I'm the CEO of Polestar.
Polestar is the new electric
car brand from Sweden.
We are the rebellious
child of Volvo,
and we want to make Polestar
the guiding star of the new era
in the automotive industry.
With outstanding design,
that is our religion.
This is the Scandinavian
pure progressive design
that we bring with
our great products.
And this is the Polestar 2.
Mickey said it.
We launched it a couple
of weeks ago in Geneva,
and we brought it here
today to the Google I/O.
We are very enthusiastic
about the joy
and the fun that the electric
propulsion brings to the car
industry.
And we take the safety--
the protection of your life--
very serious.
So we take the battery and--
like a Lego brick, we build
it into a very tight unit
with the car body, and that
is the superb foundation
for the outstanding
safety of our cars.
Range, 300 miles was a 78
kilowatt-hours battery,
and power of 300 kilowatts, on
front and rear axle, 660 Newton
meter.
So it's a very powerful,
fast, and fun-to-drive car.
For us, the seamless integration
into your digital life
is very important.
So we have the Polestar app,
which from the first browse,
to the car configurator, to
the offer of a subscription
of our car, and ordering
on-demand services like pickup
and delivery-- all of
that done through one app,
with the Polestar brand.
So the great design
on the exterior
with the iconic graphics and
the clear-cut architecture.
It's not on the outside.
It's as well our strong,
powerful point in the interior.
And while I drive that
video here to you,
with great details of our
Scandinavian interior,
I want to tell you another story
about what is great, what you
experience inside the Polestar.
Because we have promised for
a long, long time, navigation
that would be
intuitive, navigation
that would be up to date,
and we actually failed.
We failed big time from car
generation to car generation.
The same with voice recognition.
So with the Polestar,
to be new, we
have to do something radically
different in that field,
and we did.
We teamed up with Google,
and it was a great journey.
Thanks a lot, Google.
It was an amazing
partnership, and we, I think,
achieved something amazing here.
We put an infotainment system
that is powered by Android
into the car, bringing built-in
apps and optimized-for-the-car
apps and services
for our customers.
And that includes
Google Assistant,
that includes the Google Maps,
and of course, the Google Play
Store--
all integrated into the car.
So our customers, they
can enjoy the superb
artificial intelligence
of the Google Assistant
fast-learning voice recognition
to operate all the great apps
and functions, having the
hands on the steering wheel,
and having the eyes on the
road, using it all through voice
activation.
And I want to demonstrate
to you a couple
of examples of how that works.
So please.
Hey, Google, show us the
way to a Pizzeria Roma.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure.
Getting the fastest
route to Pizzeria Roma.
THOMAS INGENLATH:
So you get the way
without knowing the
name of the street,
without knowing the town.
Just say the restaurant
where you want to go.
Another example, connected to
living with an electric car.
Hey, Google.
Show charging stations nearby.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Showing results
for charging stations nearby.
THOMAS INGENLATH: So that
is a nice, reassuring list
of charging stations
that you get.
So you can navigate,
you can plan your day,
you can search for things--
all using the time in
your car efficiently
without being distracted.
I think that's a really great
major improvement of safety
while using your car
infotainment system.
Out of the Google Play Store,
you can download the apps
that you like into one of the
four tiles, and, of course,
you can swap in between
these tiles with the apps.
The car is always
connected, so you do not
have to use your phone.
The Polestar 2 software
will be updated over the air
regularly, so that the car
will always stay up to date.
We have Polestar 2 standing
here in the sandbox.
Please come and have a look.
Join the coaching sessions, and
from today on, it's up to you
to develop new apps
and be creative.
Come up with new great ideas
for apps used in the car.
Visit our website.
We have some inspiring
proposals, ideas,
how apps could be used
in the car in the future.
So please join the community
and use the opportunities
that we have with the
infotainment system
operated by--
powered by Android.
Now I would end
the session here,
thanking you for having the
opportunity to come on stage
and present, and I will do that
with a last voice-activated
action and that goes like that.
Google, please play
"At Last" on Spotify.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure.
[MUSIC - ETTA JAMES, "AT LAST"]
MICKEY KATARIA:
Thank you, Thomas.
We're very excited about
the car, and the technology,
and bringing it to
consumers next year,
and thank you for bringing
one here for all of us
to see as well.
I'm looking forward to
driving one very soon too.
The clicker is not working.
Here we go.
So in addition to
Polestar and Volvo,
we also announced our
partnership last year
with the Renault Nissan
Mitsubishi Alliance
to bring Android and the
third-party app ecosystem
to their global range of cars.
And we're not going
to stop there.
We know that having
a large footprint
is very important for developers
to adapt your apps and services
for these cars, so
we continue to work
with the rest of the industry
as well on further adoption.
I'm excited to say
that we're seeing
a ton of interest and momentum.
So please stay tuned
for more news on that.
As we finish up, I want to recap
the three in-car products where
we're investing
and offering users
and our partners a choice.
On the phone screen
itself, you heard today
about the Google
Assistant's Driving Mode.
That will be the next step in
the evolution of the Android
Auto phone-screen experience.
There's Android Auto for
the car screen, which,
since launching in 2015, has
virtually become an industry
standard, and it's
on its way to being
in more than 100 million cars.
And last but not least,
the Android Automotive OS,
our in-car embedded
platform that
will be coming to market
next year with the Polestar
2, and many more vehicles
and partners soon after.
So we covered a lot
today about what
we're doing to bring
Android into cars.
Thank you, Thomas again
for joining us from Sweden
and sharing your car with us.
Thank you, Ian, for coming
up and sharing the fantastic
insights behind the
new Android Auto UI.
You can check out both the
Polestar and the Android Auto
new UI in our sandbox today
and the rest of the week
here at I/O.
Also, if you're interested
in the details of how
to build apps for
these cars, please
join the dedicated developers
session tomorrow morning,
and check out our office
hours later today.
Thank you so much for
joining us here today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]